.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Feierliche Musik *
Das ist Enes Kanter Freedom:
2,08 m gross, NBA-Basketballstar.
Rechts davon ich:
etwas kleiner, Jean-Cosme Delaloye.
Ich lebe wie der Riese neben mir
in New York
und wollte eigentlich
einen Film über einen Basketballer
mit Schweizer Wurzeln machen.
Mr Freedom, heute reihen Sie sich
in die prestigeträchtige Liste
der Menschenrechtshelden ein,
und ich gratuliere Ihnen.
Die internationale Gemeinschaft
und meine Gemeinschaft,
die Uiguren, danken Ihnen.
Ich bin stolz, Ihnen im Namen
des Genfer Menschenrechtsgipfels
den Courage Award
für das Jahr 2022 zu verleihen.
Mr Freedom,
kommen Sie bitte nach vorne
um Ihren Preis entgegenzunehmen.
* Applaus *
Dass ich nun mit einem NBA-Star
an einem Menschenrechtsgipfel in Genf
gelandet bin,
ist der Epilog
einer abenteuerlichen Reise
in die USA,
in die Türkei und die Schweiz.
Lass uns mit Basketball beginnen!
Am 8. Februar warst du
im Barclays Center in Brooklyn
und hast mein Heimteam,
die Brooklyn Nets, besiegt.
Du hast einen grossartigen
Drei-Punkte-Korb erzielt,
dein letzter Treffer in der NBA.
Was bedeutet es,
diese Auszeichnung zu erhalten?
Heute ist ein sehr besonderer Tag,
weil ich die Vereinigten Staaten
zum ersten Mal verlassen habe,
seit die türkische Regierung
mir den Reisepass weggenommen
und meinen Namen
auf die Interpol-Liste gesetzt hat.
Aber ich wollte hierherkommen
und an dieser tollen Veranstaltung
teilnehmen.
Vor zwei Monaten war ich
bei den Boston Celtics in der NBA.
Wir haben nie
eine Meisterschaft gewonnen.
Aber mit meinem neuen Team, meinen
neuen Helden und Champions hier,
können wir eine Meisterschaft
gewinnen - denn sie sind furchtlos.
Alle Diktatoren da draussen
sollten sich in Acht nehmen.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Anfang Jahr in Boston.
Enes Kanter Freedom
spielt für die Boston Celtics.
Mein Plan:
ein filmisches Porträt
über den 29-Jährigen zu drehen.
Mein Name ist Enes Kanter Freedom.
Ich spiele für die Boston Celtics
in der NBA.
Das ist mein elftes Jahr.
Ich bin in Zürich geboren.
Ich blieb nur
meine ersten neun Lebensmonate dort,
dann zogen wir in die Türkei,
wo ich 16 Jahre lang lebte.
Dann kam ich nach Amerika.
Doch heute ist alles anders:
Kanter Freedom kritisierte
Menschenrechtsverletzungen in China
und zahlte dafür einen hohen Preis.
Die Houston Rockets verzichteten
auf den neuen Center-Spieler -
Enes Kanter Freedoms NBA-Karriere
war zu Ende.
Wenn das der Grund dafür ist, dass
die NBA mich und aus der Liga wirft,
kann ich nichts dagegen tun.
Irgendjemand muss das einfach tun.
Kanter Freedom kritisierte China,
sowie die NBA
und den Sportartikelgiganten Nike
für deren Geschäfte mit China.
Es wäre sehr egoistisch,
den Mund zu halten,
mich auf mein eigenes Leben
zu konzentrieren,
mein Geld zu verdienen
und ein gutes Leben zu führen.
Als sie meinen Vater
ins Gefängnis gesteckt haben,
begann ich,
die Menschen besser zu verstehen.
Erst jetzt ahne ich,
was all die politischen Gefangenen
auf
der ganzen Welt durchmachen müssen.
Freiheit - Freedom.
Enes Kanters neues Programm
nach der NBA
wurde anlässlich
seiner Einbürgerung in den USA
auch sein neuer Beiname.
Glückwunsch! Sie sind jetzt Bürger
der Vereinigten Staaten.
* Applaus *
Nach Wasser und Luft
ist Freiheit noch immer etwas
vom Wichtigsten für den Menschen.
Darum ist es so wichtig für mich,
das Wort Freiheit
zu einem Teil von mir zu machen.
Versuchen Sie nicht, mit dem Namen
eine eigene Marke zu schaffen?
Wenn es Menschen inspiriert, v.a.
unsere junge Generation, dann ja.
Das ist alles,
was mich interessiert.
Ich möchte,
dass alle Kinder da draussen
ohne Angst aufwachsen können.
Um Enes Kanter und seine Geschichte
besser zu verstehen,
reise ich in die Schweiz.
Hier, am Zürcher Tierspital,
schrieb sein Vater Mehmet Kanter
Anfang der 90er-Jahre
seine Dissertation.
Jeanne Peter ist wissenschaftliche
Zeichnerin am Tierspital.
Sie arbeitete damals
mit Mehmet Kanter zusammen
und vermittelt mir so eine neue
Perspektive auf Enes Kanter Freedom.
Ich sehe Mehmet stark
in den Augen seines Sohnes.
Er hat dieselben Augen
wie sein Vater.
Mehmet hatte wirklich dunkle Augen.
Seine Haare
waren auch so aussergewöhnlich.
Dieses Schwarz und ... äh ...
Ja.
Wie man es bei uns nicht sieht.
Aus dem Sohn
des begeisterten Tiermediziners
wurde ein Menschenrechtsaktivist.
Für mich war Mehmet nicht politisch.
Darum ...
Als ich das hörte,
war ich sehr erstaunt.
Ja. Wenn ich mir das überlege ...
Das ist eigentlich ...
... der Sinn eines Porträts:
jemanden ans Licht zu bringen.
Er und sein Vater haben ja
etwas zu sagen, etwas zu erzählen.
Mein Vater hatte grosse Träume.
Er wollte grosse Dinge tun.
Dafür steht die Schweiz.
Viele Menschen in der Türkei
gehen nach Deutschland.
Aber mein Vater
wollte etwas anderes machen.
Als er in die Schweiz kam,
sprach er Englisch,
aber kein einziges Wort Deutsch.
Er lernte die Sprache von Grund auf.
Das inspiriert mich bis heute.
Hans Geyer, Professor
der anatomischen Veterinärmedizin,
arbeitete Anfang der 90er-Jahre
ebenfalls
mit Mehmet Kanter am Tierspital
und erinnert sich gut
an den Doktoranden aus der Türkei.
Hier habe ich das blaue Buch.
Das ist Mehmets Dissertation.
Im Originaldruck von 1993.
"Gewidmet
meiner Frau und meinem Sohn ...
... der hier in Zürich geboren war."
Als ich ein kleines Kind war,
erforschte er all diese Tiere.
Ich war immer sehr neugierig
und fragte meinen Vater immer:
"Was machst du da?"
Er war immer für mich da.
Er versuchte immer,
mir zu sagen, dass er forscht,
um Heilmittel gegen Krankheiten
zu finden.
Mehmet kam 1991 an unser Institut.
Vorher hatte er wohl ein Jahr lang
noch etwas Deutsch und Englisch
gelernt.
Ich erlebte ihn
als stillen, forschenden Typen.
Der sehr nett zu jedermann war.
Mädchen. Hm? So. Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Wir hatten ihn sehr gerne.
Am 20. Mai 1992
wurde Enes in Zürich geboren.
Der spätere NBA-Spieler
war das erste Kind
von Gulsum und Mehmet Kanter.
Die türkische Familie lebte in der
Schweiz ein sehr bescheidenes Leben.
Um mehr über Enes Kanter
und seine Eltern zu erfahren,
spüre ich in Zürich-Seebach
einen ehemaligen Nachbarn
von Vater Mehmet Kanter auf.
Hallo, wie geht's?
- Danke, gut.
Sehr gut. Komm rein.
Möchtest du ein Bier?
- Gerne.
Okay.
Steffen Smith ist Amerikaner,
lebt aber
seit über 30 Jahren in Zürich.
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Das ist mein Sohn Till.
Hi, Till.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Steffen Smith war in den 90er-Jahren
Sänger
der Zürcher Rockband City Blossom
und erinnert sich noch genau
an seinen ehemaligen Nachbarn
Mehmet Kanter,
der sehr beeindruckt von
Steffen Smith und seiner Musik war.
Als Mehmet an eines meiner Konzerte
kam, war er sehr beeindruckt:
"Wow,
das war ja wie Michael Jackson!"
Er war ein so liebenswürdiger Kerl.
What a lovely guy.
Er war so warmherzig
und sprach immer so poetisch.
Er war wirklich
eine reizende Person.
So einen Menschen wie ihn
vergisst man nicht.
Ich sage dir:
Ich habe viele Menschen getroffen,
aber ich erinnere mich immer an ihn.
Steffen Smith und Mehmet Kanter
wohnten damals
in einem heruntergekommenen Fabrik-
areal an der Zürcher Überlandstrasse.
Schau dir das an.
Ich glaube, ich habe
400 Fr. im Monat an Miete bezahlt.
Es war schon ein altes Gebäude.
Genau hier,
wo der Kran steht, war es.
Der Kran steht auf dem Parkplatz.
Das war's. Alles ist weg.
Wahrscheinlich hätten wir es
von vorne besser gesehen.
Es ist genau da. Da stand es.
Jetzt ist da
nur noch eine Baustelle.
(Peter) Mehmet hatte kein Geld.
Er ging zu dieser Zeit ganz schmal
und sehr bescheiden durchs Leben.
Als sein Sohn geboren wurde ...
Ich weiss,
dass Mehmet sehr, sehr stolz war,
dass der Erstgeborene ein Sohn war.
Er war sehr glücklich
über diese Geburt.
Als Sohn Enes
1992 auf die Welt gekommen war,
zog die junge türkische Familie
von der Zürcher Überlandstrasse
an die Langstrasse um -
mitten ins Zürcher Rotlichtviertel.
Die sog. Gammelhäuser
wurden längst abgerissen
und dienten Familie Kanter
nur kurze Zeit als Bleibe.
Denn schon ein Jahr später zog es
Mehmet Kanter mit seiner Familie
zurück in die Türkei.
Enes wuchs in Istanbul
im Stadtteil Kadikoy auf,
einem Viertel auf
der asiatischen Seite von Istanbul.
Dort wurde aus dem Jungen
ein 2,08 m grosses Basketballtalent,
dem die Türkei
bald schon zu eng wurde.
Mit 16 Jahren wanderte Enes
mutterseelenallein in die USA aus,
um dort - bei den Utah Jazz -
ganz gross
ins Basketballgeschäft einzusteigen.
Bald aber verlagerte sich Enes' Fokus
auf sein Heimatland, die Türkei.
Enes wurde politisiert.
2013 erschütterte
ein Korruptionsskandal die Türkei.
Präsident Erdogan und seine Familie
waren darin verwickelt.
Ich fing an, die Menschenrechts-
verletzungen in meinem Land
auf den sozialen Medien
zu kommentieren.
Die politischen Gefangenen usw.
Die türkische Regierung
sah das gar nicht gern,
denn jede meiner Äusserungen
ging viral.
Leider kam dadurch
meine Familie unter Druck.
Sie musste eine Erklärung abgeben
und mich als ihren Sohn verleugnen.
Das war hart für mich,
denn es ging
um meine Mutter und meinen Vater.
Die türkische Regierung
glaubte ihnen aber nicht.
Also kam die Polizei
und durchsuchte unser ganzes Haus.
Sie nahmen Telefone,
Computer, Laptops und iPads mit.
Sie wollten herausfinden, ob ich
noch Kontakt zu meiner Familie habe.
Sie konnten aber
nichts von mir finden.
Trotzdem steckten sie meinen Vater
für eine Weile ins Gefängnis.
Aber wir machten so viel Druck
von hier, dass sie ihn freiliessen.
2016 dann erschütterte
ein Putschversuch die Türkei:
Teile des Militärs versuchten,
Präsident Erdogan zu stürzen.
Der Putsch misslang
und die Situation rund um Enes Kanter
Freedom und seine Familie eskalierte.
Der Grund:
ihre Nähe zu Fethullah Gülen.
Ihn machte Präsident Erdogan
für den Putschversuch verantwortlich.
Für die Regierung Erdogan war Enes
Kanter Freedom fortan ein Terrorist.
2017 annullierte sie
seinen türkischen Pass.
Enes Kanter Freedom wurde staatenlos.
Basketball ist populär in der Türkei.
Hier, in der Ülker Arena, wo Enes
als Junior für Fenerbahce spielte,
suche ich trotzdem vergeblich
nach Spuren
des verstossenen Basketballers.
Und auch Kanter Freedoms Spiele
in den USA
wurden in der Türkei zensuriert.
Morddrohungen gegen ihn
waren an der Tagesordnung.
Die Fans hier
sprechen nicht über ihn.
Hier wird nur Basketball gespielt,
nicht Politik gemacht.
Wir Türken mögen ihn nicht.
They don't like it.
- They don't like him?
Yes.
Vor 2015
habe ich mit meiner Familie
immer am 20. Mai
meinen Geburtstag gefeiert.
Ich erinnere mich:
Es war der 19. Mai.
Ich sass mit meiner Mutter, meiner
Schwester und meinem Vater zusammen.
Ich habe gesagt: "Hört zu!"
"Ich werde mich gegen einige
der furchtbaren Dinge einsetzen,
die in unserem Land geschehen."
"Deshalb
könntet ihr in Schwierigkeiten,
vielleicht
sogar ins Gefängnis kommen."
"Seid ihr bereit dafür?"
Meine Mutter sagte:
"Wenn du dich dafür einsetzt,
was richtig ist,
halten wir dir den Rücken frei."
Ich schaute meinen Vater an.
Er sagte nichts.
Er wollte mich
als den legendären Basketball-
spieler aus der Türkei sehen,
der sich nur
auf Basketball fokussiert.
Aber als ich jung war,
verlangten sie von mir, dass ich
immer für die Wahrheit einstehe.
In dieser Nacht hatte ich
einen Flug zurück nach Amerika.
Mein Vater und ich
riefen ein Taxi vor unser Haus.
Ich habe mich umgedreht.
Meine Mutter und meine Schwester
winkten mir zu.
Ich sagte mir: "Das ist
das letzte Mal, dass ich sie sehe."
Ich fuhr weg.
Und es war das letzte Mal.
Zurück in die Gegenwart.
Es ist Mitte Februar dieses Jahres
in Washington.
Enes steht ohne Team da,
verstossen, auch von der NBA.
Ich fühle mich arbeitslos.
Yeah.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass wir
etwas Erstaunliches getan haben,
das die ganze Welt inspiriert hat.
Es war eine,
vielleicht  d i e  grösste ...
... Bewegung
für soziale Gerechtigkeit,
die wir geschaffen haben in der NBA.
Es war seine Kritik an China,
aufgemalt auf seinen Schuhen,
die das Fass zum Überlaufen brachte:
"Freiheit für die Uiguren",
"Völkermord", "Sklaverei" ...
... "Blutspiele in Peking".
Sein zukünftiger Club -
die Houston Rockets -
liess Enes Kanter Freedom noch
vor seinem ersten Einsatz fallen.
Eine offizielle Begründung
ist bis heute ausgeblieben.
Enes Kanter Freedom verliert alles.
Ich packe meine T-Shirts ein.
Jedes einzelne hat
eine grosse Geschichte hinter sich.
Ich will sie alle behalten.
Das sind die Schuhe,
die Geschichte geschrieben haben.
Einer meiner Teamkollegen sagte:
"Das sind die einflussreichsten
Schuhe, die je geschaffen wurden."
Ich werde sie alle aufbewahren.
Ich spreche über die Dinge,
die in der Türkei passieren -
ich verliere meine Familie.
Ich spreche über die Dinge,
die in China passieren -
ich verliere meine Karriere.
Ich bin immer noch voller Hoffnung.
Ich will noch mind. sieben Jahre
Basketball spielen.
Das ist mein Ziel.
Ich bereue nichts.
Denn es ist auch viel Schönes,
Neues hinzugekommen.
Ich bin hier in Washington,
um all diese Senatoren und Vertreter
des Repräsentantenhauses
und andere Freunde zu treffen
und mit ihnen wieder
über Menschenrechte zu sprechen.
Ich habe viel durchgemacht.
Aber diese Leute
haben mich immer unterstützt.
Das ist meine neue Familie.
Dafür bedanke ich mich.
Ich spreche seit über zehn Jahren
über die Türkei.
Ich habe keinen einzigen Anruf
deswegen erhalten.
Jetzt spreche ich einmal über China,
danach klingelt mein Telefon
fast stündlich.
Letztes Jahr
hatte ich gute Statistiken
und jetzt soll ich
plötzlich nicht mehr wissen,
wie man Basketball spielt?
Nein.
Ist er grösser als ich?
Probably.
- Really?
Enes Kanter Freedom ist gross.
Doch für das
US-amerikanische Basketballbusiness
war er offenbar nicht gross genug,
um sein politisches Engagement
zu dulden.
(Mann) Enes ist ein Spieler, der
in der NBA eine Rolle finden muss.
Ich glaube, dass es eine Rolle gibt
für einen Spieler wie ihn.
Er hat seine Schwächen,
das ist klar.
Er bringt aber durchaus
noch Qualitäten mit,
die einer Mannschaft
weiterhelfen können.
Da gibt es
aus rein sportlicher Perspektive
nicht unbedingt zwei Meinungen.
Gleichzeitig ist es natürlich so,
und das ist evtl. etwas zynisch ...
... dass sein Engagement
für gewisse Themen,
z.B. für die Menschenrechte,
jetzt gerade in China mit Tibet ...
... weltweit
grosse Schlagzeilen gemacht hat.
Das sorgt sicher nicht dafür,
dass er es einfach hat.
Der 34. Präsident
der Vereinigten Staaten.
Seht ihn euch an. Zwölf Jahre.
(Gisi) China ist ein grosser Markt.
Die NBA setzt dort
geschätzt 5 Mrd. ¤ um.
Das sind riesige Summen,
die man nicht
einfach so verschenken will.
Dann kommt da jemand,
der zwar solide performen kann,
aber nicht der Wichtigste ist
und dann "Ärger" macht.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass
gewisse Teams zweimal überlegen,
ob sie ihn unter Vertrag nehmen
oder einen anderen,
der ähnlich gut spielt,
aber sozusagen weniger aufwendig
in der Betreuung ist.
Damit man sich nicht immer
nach aussen rechtfertigen muss,
gegenüber
der chinesischen Geschäftspartner.
Statt mit seinem Team
durch die Stadien der USA zu touren,
tauscht Enes Kanter Freedom
sich nun mit NGOs über die Zustände
in seinem Heimatland Türkei
oder den Umgang Chinas mit Hongkong,
Tibet und den Uiguren aus.
Enes, kannst du uns erzählen, wie du
zu dieser Arbeit gekommen bist?
In den letzten zehn Jahren habe ich
mich sehr um die Missstände
in meinem Heimatland, der Türkei,
gekümmert.
Es gibt dort
so viele politische Gefangene
und so viele
Menschenrechtsverletzungen.
Auch meine Familie war betroffen.
Letzten Sommer nahm ich
an einem Basketballcamp
für Kinder in New York teil.
Nach dem Camp wollten die Kinder
Fotos und Autogramme von mir.
Ich erinnere mich an
dieses eine Mädchen, das zu mir kam.
Ihre Eltern
sprachen mich vor allen Leuten an.
Hey, Enes, Sie nennen
sich einen Menschenrechtsaktivisten,
aber Sie sprechen nie
über die Uiguren.
Ich wollte seit Langem
etwas über dieses Thema erfahren.
Can I get a picture?
- Yes.
Wenn ich zu Hause bin, recherchiere
ich und melde mich bei Ihnen.
Can you sign my ball?
- Ja.
Es ist wichtig, über alle Menschen-
rechtsverletzungen zu sprechen.
Danke für die Frage.
- Ich werde nachhaken.
An dem Tag strich ich
den Rest meines Programms.
Ich ging zurück in mein Hotel
und begann zu recherchieren.
Was ich da las,
brach mir beinahe das Herz,
und ich habe mich ziemlich geschämt.
Ich nahm mir vor nun alles zu tun,
um darauf aufmerksam zu machen,
was mit den Uiguren
in China passiert.
Ich habe mich an Sportler
und andere Leute gewendet,
die eine Plattform haben.
An Aktivisten, Prominente, Rapper,
Sänger - wen auch immer ich kannte.
Ich habe ihnen erzählt, was
mit den Uiguren in China passiert.
Sie sagten: "Hör zu, Mann!"
"Ich finde es grossartig, was
du tust und wofür du dich einsetzt."
"Du inspirierst uns und wir lieben
und unterstützen dich."
"Aber wir können das
einfach nicht laut sagen."
Ich fragte: "Warum?"
Und sie sagten:
"Wir haben Familien zu ernähren."
Oder: "Wir verkaufen Trikots
oder Schuhe in China."
Ich fragte: "Und wenn deine Mutter,
deine Schwester, deine Tochter
in diesen Konzentrationslagern wäre,
würdest du immer noch schweigen?"
Sie hatten keine Antwort.
Jetzt muss einfach
eine Generation heranwachsen,
die Moral, Prinzipien und Werte
über Geld und Geschäft stellt.
Um dieser Generation
ein Vorbild zu sein,
trifft Enes sich heute mit Uiguren,
welche die Unterdrückung
durch die chinesischen Machthaber
am eigenen Leib erlebt haben.
(Frau) Wir haben hier Menschen,
die in den Arbeitslagern in China
inhaftiert waren -
wie im Moment
auch meine eigene Schwester.
Ich habe hier ein Bild von ihr.
Sie ist seit 2018 inhaftiert.
Für uns Uiguren setzen Menschen
wie Enes Freedom ihre Stimme ein,
weil wir selbst
uns so machtlos fühlen.
Das gibt uns etwas Hoffnung,
denn wir wissen nicht,
wann wir unsere Familienmitglieder
wiedersehen können.
(Peter)
Das sind unglaubliche Schicksale.
Man kann als Aussenstehende
nicht wissen,
welche Kräfte andere entwickeln.
Wie leben sie ihr Leben, wenn sie
so eine Last zu tragen haben?
Ich finde das grossartig,
was er macht.
Es ist Anfang April.
Ein grosser Tag
für Enes Kanter Freedom.
Ich begleite ihn in die Schweiz,
wo er vor 29 Jahren geboren wurde.
Sein heutiges Ziel:
die tibetische Gemeinde in Uster.
Hier wird er, der den
chinesischen Präsidenten Xi Jinping
als "brutalen Diktator"
bezeichnet hat,
wie ein Popstar gefeiert.
Bei den Menschenrechten
geht es um Empathie und Mitgefühl.
Man muss ihren Schmerz spüren.
Man muss fühlen,
was sie durchmachen.
Bist du frei?
Ich bin noch nicht frei, nein.
Weil ich meine Familie
seit 2015 nicht mehr sehen durfte.
Ich kann mich nicht mal mehr
an unser letztes Telefongespräch
erinnern.
Man muss für die Freiheit kämpfen.
Man sieht das an der Geschichte:
Jede Diktatur geht einmal zu Ende.
Ich weiss,
dass Chinas Kommunistische Partei
eines Tages am Ende sein wird.
Das erleben wir jetzt gerade.
Das werden wir in Tibet erleben.
* Applaus *
Thank you.
Vielen Dank.
Ich weiss das zu schätzen.
Betet weiter für uns und die NBA!
Ich hoffe, dass sich noch mehr
Sportler outen und das Richtige tun.
Es gibt Wichtigeres als Geld
und Geschäft.
Ihr
seid ein Beispiel für diese Dinge:
Prinzipien, Werte und Moral.
Ich danke euch. Freiheit für Tibet.
* Jubel und Applaus *
Wie geht es Ihnen?
Schön, Sie kennenzulernen.
Ich wünschte, ich könnte sagen,
dass ich mich an euch erinnere,
aber das tue ich nicht.
(Geyer) Ihr Vater
hat eine sehr interessante Arbeit
über die Nebenschilddrüse
geschrieben.
Wir erinnern uns gut an Ihren Vater.
Wir geben Ihnen diese Kopie.
Es ist eine sehr billige Kopie,
denn es gibt nur zwei Originale
in der Bibliothek.- Wow!
Ich habe diese Skizze
von Ihnen gemacht.
Das ist erstaunlich.
Sie sind sehr begabt.
Es wäre mir eine Ehre
und eine Freude,
Ihnen einen Abzug davon zu schenken.
- Thank you so much.
Sehe ich gut aus?
* Emotionaler Gesang *
Der Kanton Zürich mit
seiner grossen tibetischen Gemeinde
ist nur eine Etappe von
Enes' Freiheitsreise in die Schweiz.
Sein eigentliches Ziel ist Genf,
Sitz der UNO.
Hier trifft sich
der ehemalige NBA-Spieler
mit anderen Menschenrechts-
aktivistinnen und -aktivisten.
Ich stehe hier vor Ihnen,
um im Namen derer zu sprechen,
die sprachlos sind
und zensiert werden.
Denn zu schweigen,
wenn man seine Stimme erheben kann,
ist ein Verbrechen.
Deshalb will ich mich hier
für die Opfer einsetzen,
denn sie sind wie Sie und ich
das Volk der Vereinten Nationen.
Mit seiner Kritik an China
ist Kanter Freedom
in den USA auch ein Liebling
von Ultrakonservativen geworden.
Studenten der Universität Genf
wollen mehr dazu wissen.
Ich frage mich,
warum Sie sich in den USA
mit mehreren hochrangigen
rechtsextremen Aktivisten
zusammengetan haben.
Das heisst nicht, dass ich
einer Meinung mit ihnen bin.
But I get your point.
Diese Kritik höre ich oft.
Sie müssen verstehen,
dass es in Amerika
eine Gruppe von Menschen gibt,
die noch nie etwas mit Einwanderern
zu tun hatte.
Deshalb möchte ich
mit meiner Botschaft
all diese Menschen erreichen.
Eine Stimme kann so viel verändern
und Millionen von Menschen
auf der Welt aufklären.
Es geht um Menschenrechte
und ich habe versprochen,
jeden Teil des Landes zu erreichen.
Zwei Monate lang war ich
mit Enes Kanter Freedom unterwegs.
Ich lernte einen Menschen kennen,
der viel gewagt
und viel verloren hat.
So endet unsere gemeinsame Reise
statt in einer Basketballarena
in den USA
am Menschenrechtsgipfel in Genf.
Was ist Heimat für mich? Gute Frage.
I think ...
* Emotionale Musik *
Ich weiss nicht,
was für mich Heimat ist.
Mein Heimatland, die Türkei,
denkt, dass ich ein Terrorist bin,
weil ich mich gegen die Diktatur
dort ausgesprochen habe.
Die Welt ist unsere Heimat.
Wenn du nach Hause kommst,
sorgst du dafür,
dass es sauber, dass es perfekt ist.
Wir erschaffen unsere Welt.
Wir sind eine grosse Familie.
Wir müssen zusammen kämpfen.
Ich habe mal
etwas Interessantes gehört:
Wenn du ein Boxer bist
und jemanden so schlägst,
brichst du dir alle Finger.
Aber wenn du ihn so schlägst,
brichst du ihm den Kiefer.
Alle Aktivisten hier, meine Freunde,
diese Helden müssen alle zusammen
diesen Diktatoren ins Gesicht
schlagen und sie zerstören.
* Applaus *
Brauchst du einen Stuhl?
* Lachen *
Wir haben es geschafft.
Jean-Cosme war ein bisschen nervös.
Aber weisst du was? Es ist okay.
Thank you. Thank you, sir,
I appreciate it. Thank you.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022